[Music]
so next up we have just the Lord I'm so
excited that Jessica could come and have
him speak here today traveling all the
way across the country from New York
even though she did you know he used to
reside here back in the day when Jessica
worked at github
you can't azar you've you've used some
application the Jessica's sticky fingers
were involved in making along the way
Jessica let up let the electron team
will start the electron team at github
and so you know if you've been working
on anything that's had been built as a
desktop application that uses JavaScript
HTML CSS all of those good things has
been packaged up and used on a desktop
app there are lots of them around we are
we going to go to lunch okay
thanks for your talk Jessica so yes that
you may well have encountered Jessica's
work already
also Jessica now works in New Yorkers a
company called splice who do kind of
tooling and resources for musicians
heard it described as github for
musicians so the mind kind of boggles
there I've seen Jessica talk a bunch of
times before and always really enjoy her
take on like culture and the the way
teams work together and so I'm very very
excited to be also welcome here to Jam
stack conference please make a very very
welcome Jessica Lord
[Applause]
thank you so much Phil um yeah
thank you that's Phil said my name is
Jessica Lord I work at a company called
splice in New York City I work on the
backend and a bunch of very not jammy
stuff at all and but I'm so I'm not
talking about any of that today today
I'm gonna share some stories about very
jammy things I worked on when I github
and I Code for America and github is a
code sharing site and Code for America
if you don't know is a non-profit based
here in San Francisco for writing open
source software for city governments
that city governments can use and be
better at governing but first I want to
go into the statement and and really why
I'm thrilled to be here and a part of
the damn Kampf and really love this area
of the web the most and excites me is
because I really truly believe that
everyone is a developer that everyone
could be a developer that everyone might
be a developer they might be on their
way they will be a developer soon or
they actually already are a developer
but they're afraid to call themselves
that our profession is really special
that way for those of us who do this
professionally it's it's different that
we actually have people not doing it
professionally doing the stuff that we
do professionally that's different it's
not like rocket science or heart surgery
and I don't mean in terms of complexity
right because that's not to say that the
work we do isn't important revolutionary
remarkable it is and that's what's
really exciting for me about it and it's
not to say that there aren't really
brilliant people doing amazing things
but you don't need to be on the bleeding
edge fringe of web development to make
something meaningful and empowering and
there aren't heart surgery hobbyists
there actually might be and it's
definitely illegal
um but it's it's one of these ways in
which our profession is different than
other people's and I might really regret
this metaphor later so we'll see
because unlike heart surgery the web is
bigger than what we do professionally
and unlike heart surgery the web is
better when it's approachable for more
people the work we do every day is also
done by tinkerers by activists by people
on their weekends by people teaching
themselves by community leaders all
these people who aren't considering
themselves a professional developer
they're still using the tools that we
have built and contributed and are using
but I think it's important that when we
build the tools we do and create the
environments we do for web development
we think about these tools in the
context not just of other developers
exactly like us but for people not
developers but aren't developers people
yes but they're a subset of people who
could would and should be developing and
so for me and why I love the jam stack
and a lot of the work I do is because I
want to build things so that there's
more people building things and I think
it's inflates
everyone it is better experience on the
web when more people can use the web
there's this quote I love from Neal -
who is the CEO of glitch formerly bought
Creek but now fully a non glitch it
seems more important than ever to
encourage a diverse community of
creators to experiment with their
broadest set of ideas I think that's so
true and to me it's really important
because coding is a powerful literacy
and and it's not just the broadest
people out there who might be developers
or who aren't developers but I mean it's
also the people you work with because
you probably work with people who aren't
developers or people who haven't been
developers their whole life
or people who are developers but came
from a totally different stack than what
you're working on now and so I think
it's really important that we don't
think of a professional developer as the
only kind of developer and that everyone
can benefit from building things on the
web because HTML CMS and JavaScript they
still work and like Monica has showed us
browsers do amazing things like we have
these tools already and it kind of
doesn't need to be more complex than
that so where's my screen um I have this
kind of scale of web things where if you
imagine the two extremes of a single
page site and then a really big web app
I think we focus on this far end and we
make it seem like this is web
development this is where you need to be
to be putting stuff online and it's just
not true there's all this spot in space
in the middle and I've actually used
this diagram before but now it's really
clear to me that this is the jam spot of
things and so this is the area full of
things you can do that don't have to be
super complex and I want there to be
more activity here because sometimes our
projects make it out into the world and
other people interface with them and
those other people need less overhead
and then sometimes a project doesn't it
stays internal but your teammates need
less overhead - so all right the first
part is it's the story of making an
electron a thing electron is a library
that github maintains that is for
building desktop apps that work on Mac
Windows and Linux using web technology
but it used to be called atom shell and
it was a dependency an atom which is
github text editor and it lived there
and github didn't want to do anything
with it there was no vision for it there
was no play
and I had been at github and recently
had moved on to the atom team and as I
dive deeper into the atom code and
on-boarded and learned that the thing
making everything happened was this
thing called atom shell I started to
think it was actually more game-changing
than atom itself I think atom is a great
text editor but Adams shell felt really
game-changing to me and so I started to
fight for it
um and you might be surprised that there
was pushback because there was really no
vision for this to ever be anything like
atom was the dream and there was just
like no there was no plan for this and I
kept pushing and I wrote up road plans
and reasons why it should be its own
thing and I finally as the first step
got the okay to spend my full time
working on electron stuff and the stuff
that I had put on my road map and so
atom shell the core library that is now
electron was built and maintained by a
guy named Chang and so he still worked
on the core library and then I worked on
all this other stuff that I had put on
my road map as a sort of like prove to
github that electron could be a thing
that was worthy and stand on its own and
the first thing I started with was
documentation I wanted there to be one
source of truth and luckily there was
already pretty good documentation in the
electron project but I didn't want to
over complicate that I wanted there to
be one source of truth for documentation
I wanted to standardize it with a style
guide because it needed standardizing
and I want to make the most of markdown
and CSS and HTML I've been on projects
that have like atom where documentation
is this whole other thing it lives in
another repo it's dependent on a whole
other tool chain for documentation and a
whole other templating library and
there's a whole other hurdle into
onboarding just to fix the documentation
and I wanted to make the most of
exist now which I felt was good enough
and then of course a static site
generator I was like github so I used
Jekyll and what I ended up doing was the
electron documentation lives inside of
electron the repo and so whenever you
download electron you get a copy of the
documentation it's all marked down and
so I wanted to start from there that is
the one source of truth all changes to
documentation happen there and then so I
never learned Ruby at github so I put a
bunch of note scripts into my Jekyll
site that basically took the tar file
from an electron release would stream
out the docs folder read the file path
read the content of it which had now
been standardized so it was predictable
and then generate the frontmatter and
all the things that Jekyll needed so
that it could then take all of those
things stream them out of the repo and
then put them nicely into a Jekyll site
in the way that Jekyll wants them and so
yeah like I mentioned the style guide
was really important so that the format
of the documentation could be
predictable so that incoming changes
could maintain the same the same format
and also because of wanting to make the
most of CSS knowing that I was going to
be putting it on this Jekyll site and I
would have the benefit of CSS so it
could make the legibility of the
documentation a little bit better than
just reading the markdown files and so
the style of all the documentation had
to be really thought through and
predictable and so on the documentation
on the site there's also a few things
that are a little bit electron specific
but because it's pulling the docs from
the releases of electron we get to have
versioned
documentation on the site and then there
is a tldr line on all of the pages
because I feel like documentation often
times you go to the page and you have to
read through to
long paragraphs to even figure out if
you're on the right page or not so I
want people to have right at the start a
place to go and know if they're in the
wrong place or not and then electron
blurs the lines between what's fronting
and what's back end and then introduces
new complexity with having to processes
and so there's a main process and a
renderer process and so each of the
documentation tells what process it
belongs to and then because when we're
on the site and we have the power of CSS
to improve readability we can do things
like make it more clear when a method or
an event is something that only happens
on a Mac system or a Windows system but
it's really important to do this without
forsaking the original markdown because
I didn't want to do something so that it
looked good on the site but then was
horrible to read as marked down because
the markdown is the source of truth and
it's what ships with every download of
electron and so everything that had to
be done like pushing the limits of
markdown and thinking about how I'm
going to style this in CSS but have it
not looked terrible in the markdown and
so that was the bulk of the
documentation the next thing I worked on
was what was going to be people's first
electron app and there are some other
people at work will like of course we'll
do an electron in it and it should be a
scaffolding system and I pushback on
that first of all electron apps can be
anything they can be a menu bar app that
does one tiny thing with a window this
big that I mean that tells you the time
or the weather it can also be slack so
there's a huge gulf and the kind of
electron apps you can build not to
mention you can pick your flavor of
front-end framework and all of this
stuff and so I felt like that's a huge
undertaking to build a scaffolding tool
that's going to support all these
permeations
of an electron app and even if it
doesn't support all of them then who are
we to say like well we think you should
use react we don't and if you have a
tiny menu bar app like you don't need
any framework at all and so I went with
the keep it simple approach and you
clone it it's a bare-bones electron app
with an almost empty starting window you
clone the repo you npm install you npm
start and you get an almost blank
electron app you can open up the dev
tools and you can start to poke around
in it and you can especially I wanted to
think about people who weren't coming
from the desktop app space because
people who are already in this space who
are maybe working at a startup that used
like chromium embedded framework and
things like this they already got it so
I don't care about them like I care
about the people who were front-end
developers or people who didn't think
that they could ever build a desktop app
I wanted people to know that an electron
it's HTML you can open it up you can use
the chrome dev tools like you're used to
and start doing the things that you
already know how to do and so with this
little easy to clone and launch app you
like very instantly almost instantly
nothing it's not that instant um you can
start digging around and changing an
electron app but I wanted to go beyond
that because it still was really hard to
get across to people what is electron
why would I use it what are the kind of
things that I can do with it and so the
next thing I did was build an electron
app that demos the electron API and I
think it worked out really great it was
actually a really good tool for this so
that you can you can download this app
and you can go through it and you can
view the demos of the different kind of
common things that you would do
interfacing with the different desktop
system you eyes and demo things like
opening a new window and so that it
makes really clear like what this stuff
means like what what's a dialog if
you're not coming from that does have
application world like what
you might not know exactly what a native
dialogue is so this app lets you go in
and start actually seeing these things
in real time and I also wanted this app
to be a learning tool inside and out and
so the code itself is structured in a
way where everything is organized and
named so that you can match it up so
when I mentioned earlier about there
being the two processes an electron here
when you open up the code for the app
you can find exactly the name the
matching name for a feature that
happened and find the corresponding
renderer and main process files and
because it's an electron app and because
we have no Devey LeBeau in our HTML what
each page does is actually uses all of
the sample code the app gives you is the
code itself so we use know to read the
file and then append it to the Dom and
so there's also one source of truth here
so once you update the apps code the
demo app is updated there's not they're
not ever gonna be out of sync and so
that was huge for me
being one person doing a bunch of the
stuff and so that is essentially all of
the groundwork that was done and to me
this the jam stack was essentially
keeping it simple from the start was
essential so that I could advocate for
the project so that I could actually
build these things so that I can
maintain these things and then it was
easy to onboard people once it became a
real team and we got more people on it
it was easy to grow from there you might
find yourself in a position like this
too so it's not it's not always an
altruistic thing of like I'm doing this
for the good of humankind but you might
find yourself in a position and where
you need to maintain less and on board
people faster all right so the second
part is about spreadsheets something I
love to talk about and this goes back to
my background is actually urban design
and
architecture and I was an urban designer
at the city of Boston in the urban
design technology group and from there I
went to do the Code for America
fellowship which I mentioned earlier for
building open source software for city
governments and something I took with me
from City Hall into this fellowship was
a real desire to make it so that people
could edit their own content so that
there wasn't this bottleneck places
where IT had to do everything because I
felt like the web was further than that
the web was at a place where people
shouldn't be so afraid to edit their own
content and so after that year and a
grant from Mozilla I ended up with a
little library called sheets ejs for
visualizing Google Spreadsheets on a
website but I'm not gonna go into sheets
II really I just want to talk about how
great spreadsheets are and so back to
this diagram again and I think this
space is such a great space for
spreadsheets because spreadsheets are a
database with no setup that almost
everyone already knows how to use and if
you just sit with that for a second like
how many libraries like we talked about
all the hurdles of learning the modern
web stack and all the tool chains and
all of this stuff and even if you're
already a developer you have to onboard
into a new system and learn how
everything works and so something that
exists with no setup and you don't have
to teach people how to use it that's
amazing and so I am mostly talking about
Google Spreadsheets here when I say
spreadsheets but really a lot of the
stuff you could do if you're I mean if
your spreadsheet is in Microsoft Office
on Excel like if you can get it to JSON
you can still do a lot of these things
so websites they have problems and so
even if you're a professional developer
who knows how to do all of this stuff
there are certain projects where these
become hurdles even for you and their
hurdles for people who aren't full-time
developers and
Spreadsheets make a lot of this easier
or not a problem at all especially when
you think about our am I gonna have a
collaborator am I gonna be working with
someone who's not a developer and that's
one of my favorite things about
spreadsheets is because they are so
approachable that people are using them
to do radical awesome things in the very
scary times in which we live and so I
think there's so much untapped potential
about what we can do that involve so
many people with spreadsheets okay one
library I want to talk about is called
tabletop Jas and tabletop basically
gives you the data you would expect from
the Google API which the Google API
doesn't give you if you tried it if you
use it directly to get your spreadsheet
stuff you get a bunch of extra stuff
that you don't want and so tabletop
clears cleans that all up for you and
returns your columns and your cells to
you as JSON in a way that seems
reasonable and it's on NPM you can also
just use it client-side it's on a CDN
and it's pretty simple but it has some
few some options so you can use multiple
sheets if your spreadsheet has multiple
sheets you can also only use some of the
sheets if you have multiple sheets you
can use an auth key so you don't
necessarily have to make your
spreadsheet public for everybody you can
use proxies and so it is a great and
handy library and I loved that that's
because sometimes I feel like I'm just
the spreadsheet loving person in my own
corner and the docs for tabletops say
like imagine it's a read-only JavaScript
CMS that you can edit through Google
Docs
it's like Christmas or any other gift
giving celebration up in here and that's
how I feel at lease and I want to be
clear that I'm not talking about using a
spreadsheet to just make a website
that's a better design table or a grid
of cells because once you have it as
JSON all your data you can go wild with
your CSS and do whatever you want and
rep
and really cool ways so this for example
is a tool lending library site
and if you use a Google Form you also
can one prevent people from messing up
your spreadsheet if that's a concern but
you can also make it even more
approachable to people if you don't want
people to have to look at a spreadsheet
a Google form will feed into a
spreadsheet and then you can hook that
spreadsheet up to a website and there's
also no deploying like anytime someone
visits your site they're getting the
latest from the spreadsheet
I'm not fantastic you can do mapping you
can turn your spreadsheet data if you
have if you have Latin long data in your
spreadsheet you can turn it to do JSON
which she C will do for you you can also
go to geo JSON dot IO if you want to
learn more about that format but then
you can feed your spreadsheet data into
matte box Maps or use leaflet or Google
Maps you can also just avoid other
libraries altogether and just use query
strings and this isn't just for mapping
but anybody that has a query string that
matches the data you have you can start
using and then you can do totally static
data to which I have done for projects
if you have a spreadsheet that isn't
going to change that often and doesn't
have that many editors you might want to
do this you can use the version of
tabletop and know to pull down the
spreadsheet JSON write it to a file and
then use it as static data with your
site and you can also use it to backup
things that way there's also a site
called if this then that that lets you
turn like almost anything you do today
into data on a spreadsheet and I what I
like the most is that you can kind of
have your own copy of your data
essentially and like there could be
another discussion because technically
it's like on Google and I don't know the
legalities of that but in a way
you have your own data and so you can do
things like totally display your social
media in the way that you want and or
just archive it like you will have a
copy of everything you've done and a
space that I think is also really
interesting and to me
could just expand is the spreadsheet as
the CMS right like a spreadsheet can be
a CMS you could write blog posts and a
spreadsheet you could have CSS
properties saved in the spreadsheet and
it can all feed and alter to a website
and lastly I wanted to just mention the
site glitch which Monica mentioned - if
you have not played around with glitch
it is a great way to put your projects
in a space where people can avoid a dev
setup can just go straight into your
code start playing with it and making
their own version of it and so it's
really approachable onboarding
experience for people I have the
spreadsheet URL on glitch so that's mine
but check out glitch and lastly I hope
that these have been some interesting
ideas and that you think about keeping
it simple from the start because you
might be in a position where it benefits
you to keep it simple from the start it
will benefit your teammates and it will
benefit the people outside too as we
grow this space for all the people who
don't think they are developers but they
are because everyone is a developer
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]